all right following her controversial uh
testimony on anti-Semitism last week
University of Pennsylvania president Liz
McGill announced her resignation over
the weekend now our very own Sarah
Carter she's on the ground she's in
Pennsylvania where she spoke with
students earlier today I bet you didn't
have a Fox News mic flag on at the time
Sarah we welcome you
back no Sean I did not have the Fox News
mic on at the time and it was just cuz
we didn't have it but I can tell you
this I'm standing right just outside the
University of Pennsylvania and it wasn't
just the leadership that wavered on
whether or not calls for genocide
against the Jewish people violated the
code of conduct but a lot of students I
spoke with today Sean they didn't know
how to answer that very same question
and many of them equated calls for
genocide as just someone else's opinion
take a listen it was very difficult for
her and the others to talk about no we
do not accept genocide on campus as a
form of
speech yeah I think it's big news for a
reason I guess I haven't spoken it about
it with too many people at campus and I
don't really know how I feel about it
just because they're very scrutinized on
a national level I think right now and
whatever they say there's probably going
to be a lot of commentary about it so I
think it was hard for them to answer
even though don't think it should have
been could the campus then say that's
unacceptable we don't accept a call for
the Gen side of a group of people well I
think that's the question that Liz was
asked correct that's correct yeah and
clearly there's heated opinions on both
sides on this topic and I don't really
feel qualified to answer have someone
stood up and called for the genocide of
any group of people that that should not
be tolerated on on campus right I expect
people
to not be violent I can't
say my personal obviously stance on
genocide is against it but I'm not going
to force anybody my political views
while her position is difficult the
question itself was not that difficult
to
answer Sean um I got to tell you it was
a little bit mindblowing uh when you
hear people that can't stand up and say
that the genocide of any group of people
is wrong and that they would waver on
those answers but I got to tell you this
this isn't an anomaly this is the reason
why so many people are standing up and
speaking out and calling for the removal
of the leadership of MIT Harvard and we
saw what happened here at the University
of Pennsylvania with Liz Migel Sean yeah
a great report sarrow uh I'll get to
this in a minute but you have 20 % of
young people 18 to 29 that believe the
Holocaust was a myth uh this is what
indoctrination rather than education uh
get you um anyway great report Sarah we
appreciate it thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else